it's one of the special things about the
sport is that people can get just that
close to you but when they get too close
that they actually start affecting the
result of the race or affecting the the
riders then then I was here that that
line needs to be drawn there
just soso difficult to to really know
what what was going on at the time at
one second we had just just just our
heads down giving it absolutely
everything going up that mountain the
next second the three of us were all
just on the on the ground looking at
each other not not knowing what had
happened at the crowded had bottlenecked
and stopped the motorbikes that were in
front of us said they'd had to slam on
brakes in front of us and had a mouth
motive like plow into the back of me and
break break my bike completely so I
couldn't couldn't carry on and the
support cars were over a while back
behind the other riders who had been
dropped so it just seemed logic to me
just keep going there are always gonna
be people who will break the rules in in
every every walk of life but I believe
cycling has done so much to to get to
where it is right now I mean this tour
just feels so special it feels like it's
it's the first one again it's I love
this sport I love doing what I'm doing
and it's it's it's just such a thrill
for me